oh monday
you said in the text you were going to
look like a cutie you're looking cozy
you're looking you're looking super fall
like i want to cozy up on your lap
i'm looking for the blue rag on you
though [ __ ] yeah i don't think i don't
think gangsters are wearing all scenes
doug what's all saints this is all
saints yeah daddy i don't giggles is
probably where all saints i'd imagine
they do a little baby
the baby
probably we're all saints what what do
you think when you're when you're
snuggled up i like it was a fire there's
a fire you got your tv in l.a
just one of those days one of those fall
days
and it's like real chilly out you got
some stuff on what do you eat what's
your what's your uh oh boring chili
what's your food what's your go-to and
your own
turkey
you know what though it can get a little
chilly sometimes i feel like it does get
to the point where you're snuggled up
against a fire
oh a little beaver blanket
do you even have a fireplace most allied
homes i now have a fireplace in my new
place but your old one right no no most
places especially and if they do it's
like a it's one of those like [ __ ]
alcohol things that kind of burn that's
weird with a glass thing and you're like
oh just it doesn't mean
you can't buy new houses with uh
fireplaces because they uh fire hazard
yeah no uh pollution
they're yes so so so in la a couple
things they did one um they used to have
incinerators in your backyard where you
could burn like the leaves and stuff or
whatever they would do no way because
just because of pollution all right it
was causing major problems they also
have a lot of like regulations on when
you cook outside like if you have an
outdoor
yeah all that stuff well less so when
you have a commercial cooker like you
know you see people on the street
cooking and stuff they try to limit that
stuff because it can cause all kinds of
pollution so much of [ __ ] you don't
think about it yeah like when you're
painting like spray painting and things
like that the wind
messing up the ozone yeah like pasadena
spray paint so much i'm really concerned
there's a lot of but there's a lot of
like there's a lot of that no uh
construction so with construction
yeah it gives off a lot of like they
love that
i love the smell wet paint oh yeah
wait so the grill he uses
when you do when you do construction or
you're building or you're painting or
whatever this is like all those fumes
have to be taken into account like they
they are part of when when they do these
air samples yeah all that [ __ ] has but
your local house you have to worry about
grilling and [ __ ] oh got it he's not
talking about that no
no that's all regulated beforehand
anyway how [ __ ] your thing how was
denver dude
he said what would you eat oh my god hey
when you're called out like what do you
prefer to eat hey hey
hey
hey man hey let's start the podcast
what's wrong with you let's start the
party i'm just trying to get into it
oh my god you look cozy and i went off
oh my god
i was bored i'm like why
we're not construction workers you know
all the spray-painting grill yeah
because they're spray painting so much
so anyway denver was uh how was denver
dude it was amazing
yeah and by the way yeah daddy didn't
stay in boulder daddy did not stay in
boulder good now couple things about
boulder let's get into it for a second
wait did you visit boulder i did i want
to get into it because you went to
school there for yeah four years so i'm
gonna get into it for a sec a couple
things have you been to boulder before
yes it's beautiful uh so i got no
problems with boulder i got no problems
now very rei very granola very woke
very well very very very granola very um
does anybody have a job you know that
kind of thing where he's like you're
mountain biking in your your 40s it's
middle of monday and everybody's monday
yeah they're headed to the river you
guys are in your 30s playing hacky sack
yeah there's some money out there and
then there's a poetry reading with a
tattered bookstore and some coffee
you know so it's still a place where you
you're super safe
and and a lot of and and it's white yeah
well i didn't see a person with color i
saw it like the only time you'd see it
on color if they're on the football team
caucasian central yes caucasian is this
a smaller area no no no very liberal but
very white but that but that's also a
reason why it's hard for them to get
recruits
oh
oh that's interesting if you're a kid
from [ __ ] competition i don't want
shaw it's like i don't give a [ __ ] about
mountain biking in height like you're
gonna sell me on hiking like our
facilities are dope but low blood sugar
the town could use some no see you went
around people are in shape that you know
it's the most the i think it top five
most in shape city there's no there's a
lot of hiking a lot of mountain biking
people are in shape oh real foods is
packed
rouse is frowned upon that's where that
mass shooting was at ralph's now so what
a lot of people just running hiking but
there is so there's a lot of people in
great shape and there's no doubt about
that then there is a contingent of the
vegan pear-shaped sort of
you know that other thing it's
interesting vegan pear-shaped soy boy
and girls see a lot of soy boys a lot of
soy boy and girls and that's fine too
but in general there's so much it's
expensive up there daddy oh dude yeah
those houses up there i mean i went on a
hike
there you go right that's what you do up
there
this great great restaurant is it chilly
great it's great all the way around
great food doing the games great up
there yeah boulder's great man
apples just growing on the trees oh
apricots just just fruit did you drive
by john benedict bears did you drive by
john benedict i did not drive by i don't
know that's where it all went that is
yeah yeah john benedict you know the
girl got murdered
they think it was you know our uh
our strength edition coach dot crease
who's this old school dude from
[ __ ] arkansas something like that so
obviously you know the girl dies there
they found her body in the house the
house on the market forever yeah it's in
a great area yeah he said i'll [ __ ]
buy that thing everyone's like well you
know it's haunted he's like i don't give
a [ __ ] off tough dude oh sure and he's
like yeah i'll welcome the ghost and he
lived there the entire time he's that
goes and i bet you just got a good [ __ ]
and he got a steal on that house i bet
he didn't take a multi-million dollar
house
because no one wanted it
it's a big-ass house people are afraid
of the energies multiple millionaires i
bought the guy before that hung himself
and drowned his two dogs this recent
house you got oh no i know they're
you're not that you're new around oh
yeah
yeah but they knock that down
[Laughter]
literally probably this of course
but they always have to tell you they
tell you that by the way it's why it's
like the law they have the thing oh they
have the time themselves someone bought
kirk o'bane's house there's people that
live there that's investment yeah but
but here's the thing in my house
uh
yes they tore down okay but the guy hung
himself drowned his two dogs uh whatever
he was a little crazy um really and yeah
um uh totally it's totally together and
um but the funny thing is that people
there's a new build so they knock it
down they're building yeah what do you
want but stevie stevie stayed at my
house and stevie was like yeah your
house is haunted like casually i like
what he was i saw dogs i heard him
upstairs and i heard people and what i
was like hey stevie if you give in to
that my my ex my ex-wife said the same
thing all the time she goes no it's
haunted oh no i've i've seen german
shepherds and people will see that but
you know it's interesting if if the
realtor never told you about the dogs
none of this
it's all created in your mind the stevie
c ghost um when he was a kid he used to
go explore uh mental asylums that were
abandoned oh [ __ ] so yeah that's cool
yes that stuff so she's like he's like
sensitive to it uh not really he's not
so nervous he just likes doing children
yeah it's called bad parenting yeah yeah
no he had shitty parents
correct
if tiger was like dad i'm going to this
insane asylum i'm going to check it i'm
like no you're not but you know you're
not yeah yeah your imaginary friends are
crazy ghosts yeah if it's an abandoned
you know i mean it's fine but yeah i
mean i've been i've been maybe
everybody's gone to those before though
then again like comedy clubs like cobs
or something or or comedy works
think about how much laughter has been
going on in that room like think about
the the
positive energy in that room for so long
yeah but it's not like you walk in and
you're like well
the most haunted would be the comments
the comedy story yeah that's what i was
gonna say yeah you can feel the energy
in there sure now i don't know what it
is maybe it's just energy from the
admirer they say something in the world
the original gangster ran the whole
[ __ ] country it was his one of his
clubhouses and with all those secret
rooms people were getting worked over
and probably chopped up in those rooms
maybe i mean it might be haunted your
boy when uh your ghost hunter boy went
to the comedy store i think and did a
thing there
yeah oh [ __ ] i think not too long ago
damn be honest i would have saw that
did you have yeah
in denver i love denver and i love that
club and i really appreciate the fact
that they when you get into comedy works
you're packed in there you're you're but
nobody gave a [ __ ] they were just there
to have a great time they were
vaccinated and they or they had had a
negative cove test whatever it is and it
was just [ __ ] that club is electric
yeah great club is there any better like
that because they're so the ceilings are
low it's an old school and no stone
along the wall
laugh has nowhere to go it has nowhere
to go if you can't do well there you
shouldn't be in the business it's
beautiful yeah i love that i mean
i've only been to the airport in denver
i haven't like been able to
explore
you're going to stay you're going you
guys going i'm going with that you're
going to [ __ ] this week thursday
friday saturday they're going to love
you and you did the press with willie b
kathy scott hastings yep yep rick i did
his show my morning show with rick um
rick he's great he's been on that
forever the best it's the only city i
still do pressing because you all
remember
those guys have been friends of mine for
[ __ ] 20 something years we talked and i
played football cu i do press there i
didn't know them when i was fighting
ring of fire which is the local fight
scene there out of dupress there so
they've been with me the whole time dude
damn that's when that when i fought my
first ufc fight i did press there wow so
they've been like each stage with me wow
then when i do you know it's probably my
fourth or fifth time kind of works every
time i do press there
the only one where my agent's like
you're down to your press like yeah man
because yeah they're a they're they're
my friends b they're really good it's
not like [ __ ] press right yeah
they're great well i i i got some
restaurants for you i don't know if
you've been
my hometown
hey hold on no no
no wait auroras you're hey hey i got
some good places you probably never
heard of them give them a guarantee i
have don't want them daddy give me no no
i know what you like what i know i bet
i've been there i don't think i have my
go-to's there give me your go-to's uh
cherry creek grill
there's uh you've never been there
you've never even heard of it yes i have
there you have it yes what is it called
what part of denver is it is cherry
creek nope it's in it's in the area of
cherry creek yeah it's the grill there
yeah in there what do you got for me
uh denver i got i got denver i got i got
mercantile
mercantile it's in union station yep all
the restaurants union station are great
yeah but especially merchandise
i've been there daddy i went there last
time i was there some get involved in
that do me a favor get involved that
strip steak yeah that aged duck breast
that's all new about the whole unit it's
all new over there but it's right up our
alley yeah i know what you're like
what is the style mercantile uh hit him
to some food please bring him there get
him the uh i'm not the one that has bad
taste that motherfucker's got bad taste
now you roll deep you roll deep so every
time you go to dinner if you're gonna
bring them it's gonna cost about 600
bucks that's a problem yep but but at
the end of the day i need you to get out
get over there and just just take a look
because you're going to
oh no they got some that korean fried
chick chicken it'll kill you korean
fried chicken deborah has great food
dude great food great food great food i
miss denver i had the kitchen there that
was really good um
yeah at the club or whatever well the
club's right next to i mean obviously
it's a chain but capital grills right
next to it so the the club is like
downtown downtown straight downtown then
did you you didn't stay at the condo
they gave you i stand it's the best
condo crawford hotel
which was there's so many good hotels
overrated yeah i'll do this i wish you
would call me you know klopp
they're in all that business so i'll
call climbing like this is the new hot
spot stay here so when i flew down and
get my black belt he's like stay at this
hotel it was ridiculous it was oh dude
the bar the food i love it down there
that's what i mean that now that
building the union station was built in
1881 okay it is so [ __ ] beautiful in
there look at that like look at the
inside of it and then right next to that
is course look at that like like right
there all restaurants all around it's
great oh restaurant that bar right there
it's a it's beautiful man look at that
there you go we're gonna go
or whatever
uh probably not no that's just a regular
steakhouse oh it is oh okay you can skip
that the guy oh because we had you're
saying the breakfast
report yeah we didn't get that to get it
oh yeah you didn't have that they didn't
have it that time i'm friends with my
buddy um who i'm friends with
i know a guy who owns a lot of the
restaurants there right in denver yeah
and and also in boulder and liz and
boulder went hiking with him and he he
said he knows elway pretty well and he
said when elway was playing and he was a
chef elway would come in drink basically
a bottle of vodka smoke a pack of
marlboros and then the next morning he'd
be playing football interesting i don't
believe him but damn that's cool you
don't think so no
well he's no he didn't smoke cigarettes
i believe he did i don't think so he was
not a chainsmoker well i mean when he
went out i think he was drinking he was
doing all that and i've heard that from
a lot of people he was able to tear it
up him yeah joe namath those old school
guys don't name it do you know how much
older joe names was in china understand
that but i'm saying there are certain
quarterbacks back in the day like elway
who did a lot of that stuff
he's a yeah he's the beast he smoked a
lot of cigarettes look at him
no that's joe montana smoking right
there that is yeah
wow and the other pictures is that john
candy
it does look like him
yeah what is john candy you gotta have
some real balls of smoked cigarettes and
play a game the next day yeah he
apparently did a lot of that yeah that's
that's [ __ ] joey montana right there
joe montana yeah just smoking arguably
in some ways the greatest quarterback of
all time he's up there wow oh wait no
that's chief's qb
linda dawson does that not look like joe
montana though to a t and he's number
16. did you watch out to our to our uh
defense it's in black and white so we
can't tell if it's the 49ers jersey
mm-hmm but it looks identical to joe did
you watch the 49ers packers game
yesterday uh
wow came down to the last nitty-gritty
seconds aaron rodgers delivers again
they were beating the [ __ ] out of them
so i changed the channel they're up 26
to nothing unbelievable my broncos 3-0
baby first place in namc west that's
pretty impressive west they beat the uh
they beat the [ __ ] out of the jets no
they haven't played the raiders are
really good that's right yeah the whole
ifc west is balling beside the chiefs
are struggling right now did dallas win
i think they play tonight okay that
might be the money are the cardinals
doing good yeah cardinals they are yeah
murray's
it's him or uh carr for the hi for the
mvp so far whoa did you watch the
anthony joshua you sick
yes
let's take a little break from chatting
with the bros because grubhub is
launching their new brand new campaign
we serve restaurants grubhub loves
restaurants from the food to the passion
termination of the people behind them
they know that restaurants reputations
matter and they'll be damned if that
reputation suffers because of them
because good food deserves good service
delivered fast fresh exactly how
restaurants intend it to be even if it's
showing up at your crib restaurants work
hard to serve their customers and now
grubhub works even harder for
them whatever you're doing you're a
gamer you're into some freaking show you
don't want to take a break you don't
want to make dinner let them cover it
for you man we got you covered grubhub's
got you covered again grubhub works hard
to serve restaurants so they can work
hard to serve you today's grubhub's
doing a little extra for panera get free
delivery perk on your first order from
panera 15 or more order through the
grubhub app or online grubhub we serve
restaurants you know what i'm not going
to say anything nobody disagrees with
everybody should be able to afford their
medications all right if you can't i got
something for you check out rx they help
you guys find the lowest price on
prescriptions every time with good rx
you can instantly compare prices for
your prescription at every pharmacy or
neighborhood and save up to eighty
percent
eight zero percent eighty percent gunner
x is free and easy to use and many times
it's often cheaper than user insurance
copay or medicare with goodrx you can
find discounts for your prescriptions
over seventy thousand pharmacies like
cvs kroger walgreens rite aid vons
walmart and more good rx is the number
one most downloaded medical app and
millions of americans use good rx to get
affordable health care every month all
right start saving up to 80 on your
prescriptions today go to goodrx.com
fighter that is good rx.com fighter
goodrx.com fighter eighty percent
corex is not insurance but can be used
instead of insurance in 2020 good rx
users receive an average savings of over
70 percent of retail prices oh six obese
right he's a beast slick boxer he's a
well he's a he's a school he comes i
think he's gonna he's a cruiserweight
lomanco he's a cruiserweight yeah like
180 189 or something that was 220
um but i i just think you know
i have a theory on joshua which is that
um i think that when you're that rich
that much of a superstar and you have
that many other options it's hard to
fight a russian dude who's that
who's that who wants i found he was he
could have been more aggressive like he
just
looks more tentative i don't know if
it's money i think i think for joshua
sometimes he just doesn't show up and
like he he was supposed to win he was a
huge favorite so i think he over like he
has a problem with overlooking guys he
did the same thing with andy ruiz yes
right and then i bet you he would beat
usyk if they fought again do you think
he just overlooked it you think but or
maybe he's not a boxer right uh he's not
a skilled azusa yeah he's more skilled
than andy ruiz and i think he's more
skilled than deonte wilder not as
skilled as tyson fury right but i think
the problem is is that was a mandatory
and now he [ __ ] lost so it [ __ ]
everything up but i think you know he's
looking at fury and wilder and when
those don't happen it's such a letdown
but you're still fighting at the highest
level you have to defend all these belts
yeah and who sick's no [ __ ] punk man
you got to get
out of but maybe not tyson he's right
there he skill wise better than all of
them is he's too small for uh
uh tyson fury usyk um i don't know i
think i i don't think he's gonna finish
any of them but as far as slick boxer
he's better than all of them
tyson's [ __ ] slick so it's tough but
yeah he's the one who had trouble i do
think usyk does i think he gives uh
wilderness while they're a big problem
we'll see because wilder's with a new
camp
apparently he's working his job a lot
but also if wilder you know if usyk
lands those shots and then wilder slams
one it's it came more correct
he does stand here like this
and while they're land and they land
there's nothing in there they say nobody
hits harder no no no never i mean top
[ __ ] three of all times you got ours
like yeah that's right god gives god
gift yes he hits you
but and his fundamentals aren't his foot
comes off the ground yeah it's loopy but
it's just yeah i've seen i've watched
like his highlights this is but they say
and he has a new camera his new camp is
working on his [ __ ] jab his piston
jab they're like why are you not using
you got that crazy right use your jab so
it's gonna be really interesting when he
fights tyson fury to see if that jab can
get it's tough to figure that out when
you're fighting tyson fury it's tough to
catch him with that why is that at that
level to throw that in like oh now
you're gonna set the right hand up with
jabs and you've grown up your entire
life not doing that yeah and here's
tyson fury the best boxer who's seen
that we have seen jabs a couple times
seen jabs had to get under a jab
yeah but uh wilder's issues can be he
can't fight off his back foot yeah and
fury knows that and completely that so
he's going to probably crowd him
pressure him force him to fight his back
foot so
there's not like there's not enough days
in the year for him to try to figure out
how to fight off your back foot yeah now
i still have give him a really good
chance of winning though
uh wilder wilder yes because of that
right
yeah and i don't know and with fury you
don't know i don't know if i'm buying
the covet thing to push the fight i
don't the the mental game like for him
it's all mental right he's better than
everybody yeah but if you don't come
mentally sharp he loses so we'll see
that's right it's a great fight though
but uh did you watch ufc 266 did watch
you you're watching your green room or
did you watch it i watched it in my
green room in fact and i watched uh and
i i think i was so impressed with nick
diaz i just his boxing and his you know
i thought he did a great job but um
i just think you know he broke his nose
i think he got hit too hard and he was
like
i don't want this anymore
i don't want to do this i'm going to
take a seat yeah and he's the only he's
one of the few people that can quit and
we just go you're still such a badass
yeah i mean online he's getting
transferred people call him
which is weird hilarious yeah which is
so stupid that guy's earned that but
also took six years off and then going
into the fight he was nervous i was
talking with our boy about it i'm like
man diaz seems off he's like no that's
why we love diaz typical stuff i'm like
no he really doesn't seem like he wants
to do it this time and they see in the
fight like
he showed a good fight definitely looked
like took six years off definitely
looked 38 like that wasn't a young
vintage nick diaz
and i think
there are some red flags i don't cheat
on blow about there's all these red
flags leading up to it and we're just
like ah nick diaz he'll be fine and then
he gets in there why because he was
basically saying i don't want to fight
he said that before and then he's game
once he gets in there he just hates all
the build up yeah but then you see like
when he was in knock down he almost
forgot to take his shirt off and get
vaseline so you're like right he's not
mentally checked in and then he gets in
there and then usually he's like
scowling at the guy and like look at him
like flip him off no matter who it is
this time he's looking at the mat most
of the time he's looking at the mat
and then you know through that weird
wheel kick that you could throw you know
and stats
just kind of taking shots and i think
the other red flag is the ufc made it
five rounds why the [ __ ] would you make
it five rounds guys i've stayed back in
six years how crazy is that so i think
with nick i don't think he's quitting
he's like
he's alright i've thrown so much volume
at this guy he's not going he's coming
forward i mean hit with shots yeah all
right and i have two more rounds i'm not
dude i'm not and he's very conscious of
ct and injury he's like [ __ ] this how
much and then also what else and i'd
love to know the backstory jake shields
came out was like nick's such a you know
legend he took this on six weeks notice
he didn't say he didn't want to take the
fight but someone was like oh you can't
think nick didn't want to be in there
and jake just responded back snakes
everywhere
i mean like you know like people forced
to because he got i think he was the
highest paid on the card wow so there's
something i love that he got paid but
you can see his face he's taken a [ __ ]
load of damage over the years so you're
talking about a guy who's never stopped
working out by the way in training he's
been he's been boxing marathons yeah if
he's been boxing i think he has been
boxing jiu jitsu i was very impressed
with his boxing actually i thought he
connected a shitload with robbie long
that's
like a lot of robbie's four five of his
is the way it goes yeah
robbie does
he head hunts yeah he's a killer yes a
monster yeah i just yeah i think people
got to realize too you know we're like
oh he did it for money yeah yeah
everybody in here everybody in here okay
you guys can get paid if you don't have
to come in nobody's coming in
so for him it's like yeah of course you
gotta pay it's a [ __ ] job but then
also
because he has such a loyal fault in
following stuff like that
it's also like
you know when he was big in his prime
guys weren't getting paid dude so he
can't just ride off on the sunset and
count his dollars like he needs this
money he sees his brother getting big
money and he's like what the [ __ ] the
biggest money yeah fighting conor yeah
so so he's like so it makes financial
sense i do not think he would ever fight
if he didn't kind of have to or didn't
see millions of dollars and i will
always watch but i want to know what's
going on with this team i don't know if
you see nick diaz again i don't know i
don't think his team i don't think
anybody can control nick diaz i think
nick diaz's genius is the fact that he's
just such a
such an anomaly he's such a and that's
fine but yeah and then those fighters
end up broke with ct that's right so he
needs people around him who need to set
things up for him so that brings me to
the brian ortega fight
and he's only lost two fights
yeah he's taking a lot of damage and he
should have that and i in my opinion
that this is a incredibly talented
fighter you know he's willing to die in
there and i think that fight should have
been stopped in the third [ __ ] round
no
because he got the guilty and they got
the triangle i don't give a [ __ ]
so he took so much damage not a title he
was taking crazy damage and i don't see
i don't think the juice is worth the
squeeze you take you you could possibly
first of all you got brain damage you
also can take a lot of time off his life
in that fight yes he might get lucky he
wasn't getting beat up that bad really
should have stopped his face okay so so
all i know is this the doctor was there
for at least a minute longer herb dean
cameron was what's going on because
apparently he was answering the
questions wrong when they were doing
this his he he was asking him just to
follow with his eyes keep his head still
he went like that that's a sign that
something's going on you're not seeing
things i just hate to see you can't do
that fight you can't you just can't oh
man well that and this ain't for you no
i'm saying it's not for you it's not for
me that's why then then i like boxing
more because boxers are boxing if you're
getting your head kicked in like that
they'd stop the fight and for me if
you've got it it's the rodriguez thing
you got a young guy like that with that
much promise that much marketability as
your corner oh and i'm sorry also they
had to help them off the campus which is
illegal if your team have to help you
off it's called a tko you're not allowed
to do that they helped them off nobody
saw that and they walked them back to
the thing and i i in my opinion this
kid's gonna fight every time but i think
he was like how do i deal with this
[ __ ] pressure you know he's not
dealing with the pressure well who
uh ortega yes he answered back but that
[ __ ] valonsky for whatever reason on
that night is a killer and is and is
putting that kind of pressure on that so
you just always throw in the towel when
it's not going your way when it's when
it's a when it's a kid with that much
fight so so let's stop it 100 so here's
the thing
so let's say we take your thing and you
could not be a coach for this reason so
brian ortega his first fight his first
five fights in ufc he was down on all
score cards right and pulled off the
submission in the third round cool and
that's how you got the title i got you
and you almost did it again so yep
almost this is mo so now let's go off
what you want to do he wouldn't have a
career you would have stopped those
fights before he pulled it off well it
was stopped you've been first i was
stopped he did have a fight stop what
was it against uh
uh max max so that was that was smart
they stopped that taking that kind of
damage when i see when i see his head
that's swollen and he's not answering
questions properly i'm stopping that
fight and i'm stopping that fight
the audience wants to fight they're
they're laughing with blood in their
mouth i get it at the end of the day i
see brain damage and i see taking years
off his career now he won that fifth
round
i do not care and look at his face so
boxing would stop that was just going
off his face
yeah he was taking such a beating no now
real quick um there's been more deaths
than boxing than there's mma yeah that's
fine that's fine way more
close but boxing's also been around
longer there's a lot of things about
boxing
i've seen it
hold on no hold on there's been more
deaths in boxing in the past five years
than there has been mma there was a
recent one where they they i can't
remember the boxer's name they uh his uh
corner had stopped the fight and dude
ended up dying
maybe that night or like the next the
next day or something like that
the point of boxing is constantly
hitting with mma you got wrestling it's
three rounds yeah yeah yeah but the po
the points
but like so those fights you were
talking about was he was he getting as
much damage as he was on which one's
right well the ones where you said hit
you he scored low he's getting [ __ ] up
yeah he's been he's gone
he pulls it out because his submission
game's insane yeah okay yeah and he
almost i mean volkanovsky said in the uh
post press conference he's like that's
the closest i've ever been there being
choked out yeah he's like i was gargling
and
he's like give me my head i was like
well this is how it goes yeah i'm gonna
lose my belt here we go and he's like by
the
grace of god willpower i powered through
and he let go so this corner probably
just knows like oh or this is ortega so
again it's actually to my point ortega
is insanely talented yeah could be a
champion not yet maybe could be or
certainly will always be that guy with
that crazy game so what you do is you
stop the fight
you start to fight in the third round he
wants to keep fighting everybody's like
what the [ __ ] you should have kept it
going for this reason you have more
fight left in you i don't know what
those two rounds where he was taking
another hundred shots to the head it's
going to do to his long-term career it's
just not the game it's just not it's got
to be the game it's not the game it
should be the game then don't watch
fighting no you're wrong i'm sorry you
won the fifth round it doesn't matter
does that mean he still could compete at
what cost are you talking about you so
you're worried about guys getting hurt
i'm worried in the u.s i'm worried about
i'm worried about you when you see a
dude who's not for whatever reason
don't sign up for that you don't don't
sign up all of us sign up for that no
not that kind of thing if you're a
corner title your corner third round yes
if your corner can't see that you're
getting your head kicked in that way
then there's something wrong
it because because you you can
you have a lot more fight left there are
more fights for him now we want to see
it now we go like this business-wise
even even business-wise we just stopped
that fight you start that [ __ ] fight
we want to see that again oh no you know
that's what you don't know the ufc i
don't feel like you have season go
you're never gonna title fight again
you're down on the cards and getting
beat and you throw in the towel he's
never gonna get a top shot again that's
not the way that that works what do you
mean because they stopped it yes
yeah dana's gonna punish the corner
guarantee it
guarantee it i don't know about that if
you're just throwing the towel every
time your fighters lose them that's how
every time i'm talking about when your
fighter's getting [ __ ] crushed in the
head like that and he wakes and he walks
up and he can't see and they have to
take an extra minute and a half or
whatever to ask him because he's
answering questions wrong get the [ __ ]
out of here herb dean had to come over
there and herb dean is not allowed to do
this so two things happen two things
happen that are illegal one herb dean
said how many fingers do i have up he
holds up one okay the second thing i
heard that's not illegal i don't believe
the rest is allowed
of course i don't think the referendum
is 100 herbicides the doctor does that
no he doesn't hurt can do that and if he
says i can't see they bring in the
doctor yeah and then if the doctor does
it and he says i can't
the doctor was taking a long time
in my opinion the doctor was there
asking him questions okay something was
going on and vogue volanosky said yeah
he was answering the questions wrong
that's why herb dean came over and goes
what's going on that's what he says okay
so now then i hear brian ortega go yeah
i'll i'll be all right or something like
that
to me man it was just it was and the
biggest thing is when i saw them have to
help him off the mat and walk him to the
stool [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here man
i was like that's like in between rounds
look yeah that could be exhaustion i
would suggest also that if you want to
do that okay i think that took i think
that's short in his career and is that
worth it okay and if you say that's the
game i i don't agree but okay
but what if you ask brian ortega and he
says if you want to stop i already fired
all you you don't ask that [ __ ]
he's a warrior he'll die on there that's
not who you ask never ask a fighter
they'll die so you ask the coaches yes
yes the the coaches are there to protect
you the coaches should see that that is
live to fight another day you're young
you're a badass you have huge market
share let's protect the goose that lays
the golden egg that's what i think
i would have 100 percent stop
you just can't i'm i'm i'm with you for
the safety you just can't
not see anything definitive
yeah i believe that that is
apparently not you're not allowed to do
that
but but you said even after this beating
he was close to like choking him out the
dude's incredible dominatrix he was yeah
and he has anyone let's say he stopped
in the third or taken one the fifth
round and there's one the rounds of the
year
and he got a so and that's the other
thing so they're in it for money right
yeah they're prized fighters yep so if
you stop that fight you you're
ineligible for the fight of the night
right and he got fi the night so he got
an extra fifty thousand dollars which is
a ton of money too okay
yeah uh not worth it but okay
you know all of it's i i have a big
problem with it i was fighting it i
would have stopped it you should stop it
when you have something when you see
that
you just
maybe before you have doctors you know
yeah well the doctor didn't stop it
yeah he might have been inexperienced
and a little bit influenced by the crap
yes it was a dumb
doctor not to do it but even with him
saying he can't watch it
he won the fifth round if he would have
got beat up in the fifth i would agree
with him he did get beat up he won the
fifth round it doesn't matter he took so
much more it does matter the judge's
game of the fight he took so much more
damage than those last two rounds and by
the way but yes
it's also a title fight
this isn't a regular fight night this is
everything that he's dreamed of don't
care title fight don't care not for you
live camera live to fight another fight
it's the second time you have title shot
the chance him getting back there is
not great maybe just one shot it's not
for him you know maybe that maybe that's
the case well not if you're a coach i'll
never give it
no he'd live to fight more and he
wouldn't have brain damage i mean it's
what they do be no
no ray damage
you you there's a way to protect
somebody from getting that kind of brain
damage not a ton of fun if i'm with you
if there's a regular like fight night
like main event but for a title fight
you can't you just can't yeah
that's not the game
yeah i don't i don't like it anymore
than you do that's just not the game
it's just not what these guys do it's
just not
yeah it's not what they sign up it's a
brutal sport it's the brutal sport yeah
it really is yep it bums me out it
[ __ ] really does it bums me out yeah
it's a tough he's such a he's that kid
is young and such a good looking kid and
so talented and i hate that [ __ ] i just
hate it it's [ __ ] dangerous man when
you see these guys connecting like
bologna is such a [ __ ] animal
kinky goose you know that's mixed
martial arts the highest level you know
i guess so that's just what it is is
there a way to not get hit in the face
that much of your brian o'tiga takes a
little longer it changes fighting style
yeah well
so could nick diaz
like how do you not have this argument
for nick although i'll tell you what i
see with nick diaz i see much better
defense when i was watching nick what
impressed me about that was him in that
in the corner kind of deflecting moving
he just knows how to he sees
that but there's no head movement
there's no footwork but a lot of those
shots were glancing i was really
impressed but a lot landed he broke his
nose and then he sat down and quit yes
yes but nick was always pretty good at
getting avoiding that stuff you know but
he has fights of the night saying
slugouts and that's what he's known for
and you love him for it that's why he's
a fan base i love nick because nick i
never saw nick really get hurt the only
time i saw nick get hurt was he got
dropped by paul daley and then he dude
he's got some leftover wars though he's
had some more some warts that's some
more the business yeah again but but
also but also with with nick like that's
the reason he was like right i'm out
yeah like there's no yeah i'm out i mean
how much can you do after a while you
see this stuff you see it what's
interesting to me is you just see these
wars wear on people and they're warriors
but you just
it just starts to give you either glass
jaw or just it just you know that's the
game b unfortunately that's the game
there's got to be a better way to
protect the people like that
turned into grapplers
like like nick diaz has some of the best
juicers in the world so
you know for nick if he didn't want to
eat those punches or save his brain
cells yeah grapple more dude yeah well
let's go tell nick diaz what's funny
about those guys is if you have two
grapplers they just don't [ __ ]
grapple they just stay punched in the
face yeah they're just like i'm gonna
[ __ ] bang with you because i don't
want to have you get positioned on me i
don't want to get tired you might turn
the corner and punch me in the face but
think of brian ortega it's like he has
such an advantage in grappling over a
volcano right but he really doesn't he
didn't attempt taking well his coach
said hit him with a blast double hard to
do yeah easier said than done with those
[ __ ] legs and all that but the thing
about we fought max holloway straight
striking one he took so much damage yeah
so again so to your point the only way
to for you to be comfortable watching
mma is these guys need to grapple more
well someone because that's why we don't
get brain damage like you see curtis
blades yes i don't think i mean he could
fight tomorrow yeah
he got neat in the [ __ ] head well
that's like khabib that was like john
fitch a lot of those guys just would
[ __ ] hold you down and punch you in
the face and i get it it's not that
exciting you don't have a career dude
yeah you're not going to get paid the
big bucks but with i mean khabib did
because
his jiu-jitsu is so dynamic even after
taking that [ __ ] i mean that triangle he
almost caught him with that [ __ ] the
fact that
he got out of that [ __ ] it's nuts nuts
that's nuts
i mean he's just able somehow to do it
he's just made of different [ __ ] but so
i if i'm if i'm if i'm ortega's coach
that's what i'm saying i'm saying use
your fanta your jiu jitsu is so flashy
and special use that [ __ ] then again
then again the higher level guys don't
really care
they just post up and punch you in the
[ __ ] face you can't you also got to
be careful because you'd again dude you
got to crack some eggs make an omelet if
you want to make a million bucks you
want to crack some [ __ ] eggs and you
want attention yeah you gotta crack eggs
and eggs people getting punched and
knocked out and receiving ct it's
literally the name of the game yep the
name of the game you know what time it
might not be for me for real
yeah i don't know
it's going to continue with how you feel
you know what i'm saying like there's
nothing they can do it bothers me and
maybe also these guys are
just so much better at striking it's
what they work on with high level
coaches now with boxers i feel like
they're hitting
more accurately harder i don't know man
i don't know it's like they're better
athletes maybe maybe yeah let's take
another little break with the boy boys
the boys boys because cash back credit
cards are so 20 20. earn bitcoin instead
man it's the hotness right now blockfi
has the world's first bitcoin rewards
credit card that lets you earn unlimited
1.5 in bitcoin on all qualifying
purchases all right introducing the
block 5 rewards visa signature card it's
the easiest way to get bitcoin by just
making everyday purchases man you're
buying stuff you're getting bitcoin all
right grow your bitcoin portfolio when
you buy your groceries pay your bills
fill up the gas at the gas station
whatever it is man food all that stuff
we got you covered man you're paying for
it anyways
make a little with bitcoin you can earn
1.5 back in bitcoin on all qualifying
purchases with no reward limits plus
there's no annual fee no foreign
transaction fee just bitcoin earned on
every single qualifying purchase now
it's time to start or ramp up your
bitcoin portfolio for those of you that
already have one bitcoin saw 230
annualized return in 2020 in fact
bitcoin was the best performing asset of
the last decade outperformer nasdaq 100
by 10 times according to yahoo finance
what's up blockfly is the leader in
crypto and was named forbes fintech 50
list
in 2021 all right right now you guys you
ladies and gentlemen kiddos viewers and
listeners get a bonus of 25 in crypto
after you make your first purchase with
the credit card when you sign up at
blockfi.com
fighter that's 25 buckaroos in crypto
deposited right into your account after
you make your first purchase but you
have to use the rl urlblock5.com
fighter start earning bitcoin back on
all your qualifying purchase today
blockfi.com
fighter
not all will be eligible geographic
regulatory and underwriting restrictions
apply fees and terms subject to change
additional terms of service at
blockfly.com block fly is a financial
technology company banking service
provided by evolve bank and trusts
member fdic
blockpy.com
fighter yeah
but like the nfl you know obviously
their ratings are down but
even tom brady was like yeah it's the no
fun league dude we can't like somebody
gets hit there's a flag oh god like what
are we doing yeah and that's all
because the controversy knock the guy
down you just kind of like jump off you
hit him wrong or you slide into a
quarterback's knees and then if you
celebrate like they're getting rid of
everything and there's so much backlash
you can't celebrate a touchdown uh you
can you can't you can't do you know what
i did but but but if like if
if you're running like there used to be
a i used to have this i used to watch
for my football games called um
yeah i think it was hard or uh forget
the name of the nfl tape of just all
highlights of guys getting [ __ ]
concussed yeah that's what we used to
watch like that was the nfl
even tom brady's like it's too soft now
it's just not even the nba is too soft
now and we get ratings across the board
yeah you know huh like i don't know why
i did not know about football i didn't
know you couldn't
when the quarterback the guy tripped him
uh i was on uh green bay yeah you can't
but no tripping that's stupid but he
just stuck his leg out can't do that
you could never do that no no i didn't
know that yeah just [ __ ] you know if
he's like no
which i think should be right so if i
was running you were behind me you were
faster and you just kicked my leg no way
no way you can't do it well if you get
tangled up sometimes that should happen
sometimes the trip happens but if i'm an
offensive attacker and your linebacker
blitzen yeah and i'm busy on this guy i
can't stick my leg out i did and then
quarterback trent i was like that's a
great move yeah and he was like
but he'd rather get that penalty in his
quarterback get lit up oh yeah yeah oh
that's interesting yeah [ __ ] that's been
the case always i didn't know yeah no
tripping no [ __ ] and you can't hide
low guys what is that so like i'm
engaged with you on top and then another
guy takes your legs out you can't do
that
that's [ __ ] crazy that's like some of
those rules make sense yes yeah but the
hit ones it's like i just basically
can't hit a helmet to helmet like if a
guy's like a defenseless receiver it's
like all right it's football well also
like now now your your record as a
quarterback is gonna yeah you're gonna
shatter a lot of records if guys can't
crush you yeah you're gonna take your
time in the pocket
now if i've got the ball you can crush
me though right yeah yeah are you like
oh well i can't go home with the helmet
though or i can't go low if i hit you
too hard i'm gonna get a penalty can't
go low what do you mean low or five you
know how they should like dig them into
the ground yeah that'll be a penalty
like i got a hit and like like put my
hands out
like oops
they called the no fun league that's not
yeah no it's not good also i'm not
looking at quarterback records now yeah
well it's not good like you know brett
favre came up when he was getting
[ __ ] just crushed the thing about the
receivers like michael irvin and jerry
rice like dude those guys just get
molested
to get open now you can't touch the guy
you can't [ __ ] touch the guy they
just don't want injuries
it's so stupid yeah quarterback i get
the rest of them let them go man
it's football yeah it's football
it's football
oh i thought brendan was about to have
his moment on the plane dude oh my god
we're hoping for like a wild like
customer yeah so we're sitting we're on
southwest flying to san antonio yeah and
we sit down behind the emergency uh you
know where the emergency exit is and the
chairs and this big black guy sits in
the middle he has a hat on and the you
know gay store just comes out you know
how they do it before you take off
you're scared everybody comfortable you
know if they're in case of mercy are you
good with uh all the the you know stuff
you have to do and yes yes yes the guy
goes
sure
no no he said don't ask me don't [ __ ]
oh yeah he starts off he goes so it's a
real small gay stories so he goes are
you capable and willing to help with
assists we need to and you know the
girl's like yeah next are you capable of
willingness this yeah you sir the big
black guy goes don't ask me no
[ __ ] questions and he goes
you know you can tell the guys like what
he was i said don't ask me no
[ __ ] questions you don't
deserve right ask me questions and he's
like
no sir you're in the emergency exit so i
have to ask you this like legally in
order for us to take out a few questions
because you're not gonna ask me no
goddamn questions and he goes dude and
he can tell the guy he's like please
just it's a yes or no and he goes sure
and he goes
you can you can't do that just yes or no
so the plane can take off if you don't
be delayed everybody's have to get off
and he goes then you better [ __ ] go
get somebody because i'm not moving
straight up so then he go the little guy
go gets another bigger gay guy so
another bigger stewardess comes oh he he
came with it and he's like sir
it's a yes or no you're gonna tell us
yes or no or this plane's not leaving
and he goes i told that [ __ ]
sure and he's like no it's not hold that
[ __ ] yeah yeah
and he goes and then he said something
he goes i can read [ __ ] and he
goes dude i'm just asking yes or no and
we can get started and he goes i'm not
answering [ __ ] and he was then hearing
me escort off the plane yeah he goes
then escort me off the plane and he goes
you better go get help and the the gay
store it's like you're looking at the
help yeah yeah i had my seatbelt on and
i was like [ __ ] so i took the house
right i took my seat belt off i'm like
this here we go oh they haven't like
here we go i was like this this dude is
going to get annihilated so i was just
going
to do jokes big boy he's big big big boy
i'm going to choke him out no i just
joke around he won't see me coming
anyways
my god damn i look at your pelvic here
we go yeah i was like here's your moment
and then he's like you better [ __ ] go
get help and so the guy's like [ __ ] and
i like to show i'm like dude they're
gonna make elves get off they're gonna
tase this [ __ ] guy it's my whole
ordeal yeah i'm gonna be late to the
[ __ ] show i'm like this [ __ ] i
kept it loud i kept going this [ __ ]
idiot hoping he'd here
what a [ __ ] he wanted him to say oh
my you're praying praying you'd say
something and then uh the guy's leaving
his wife's two rows up and she's like
sir please you know he's just upside
down like people asking a question the
guy's like sorry it's the mercy bro like
this is what i have to do and she turns
around looks and goes it's yes or no
yeah how long would she start yelling
yesterday nothing for everyone she's
like yeah no what is wrong with you
and then uh she goes like what happened
she's like what happened how are you
fighting
no
and then the store's like uh sorry we
have to go get like the cops and get
them off here and she goes no no please
we have this thing she's like how about
i switch seats he's like alright if you
switch seats you guys can stay on the
plane yeah so this is just
still talking [ __ ] yeah
as he's walking through the new scene
he's talking [ __ ] dude she said
she sat down
it was just so random because don't ask
me
you're not gonna win like my buddy is
macho my they their guy said uh he's
walking to the plane on the tarmac it's
a small plane so he has his mask off all
right and he hates the mask thing yeah
sure so
he's [ __ ] walking and a dude one of
the marshals goes sir put your mask on
please as he's outside yeah he's about
to walk on the plane so my friend goes
my friend goes what
the guy goes you gotta put your mask on
it's a marshall hey because yeah you're
going on the plane um and my friend my
friend does this he just goes like this
he goes
what
no in his face yeah he goes he goes i
will when i get on plane it gets too
close the guy reads his behavior and the
guy goes
the guy goes yeah that's cool he goes um
so now now you're not getting on the
plane yeah and my not going to work out
my friend goes look i got to go meet
this thing i just want i just couldn't
hear you he goes i appreciate your
apology you're not flying today
i mean yeah my buddy was like he can do
it like this and his girl he's his
girlfriend so he's a living girlfriend
was like you're a [ __ ] but it's also
like way to go dude right like what do
you how do you think it's going to go
down but that's what that martial that's
what the flight attendant said too he's
like you know like you're we'll put you
on the next flight you're not going to
sit on the merch road but if i take you
out of this fight you're on the fight
it's not until 6 00 p.m it's 8 00 am
dude oh dude like you know you're gonna
be sitting around like what are you
doing dude
like how stupid can be then i was
already annoyed because big girl sits
i'm 13 c and it was southwest so it's
you know 13 was our gate there's first
one i have my headphones on and i go
what she was i'm 13 c i think you're in
the wrong seat i go no it's southwest
lady yeah and she's like well i'm 13 i'm
like no you're
you're gay 13. and she's like what i'm
like it's the game this is like a cattle
call you just sit down where you [ __ ]
fit in meanwhile they say that
at the start like as soon as you walk on
they tell you you can sit anywhere
there's no assigned students already
annoyed in that stupid [ __ ] in front of
me dude it's southwest also yeah please
sir sir please but i said would you it
was pretty loud too mister everyone was
like yeah and then the lady next to me
was like so where are you from
i was like like why was all going down
he sounds like he was a bit of a bully
yeah yeah and i mean i think he was
having a bad day
it was just so quick oh is there like
this
not a small guy either no those tasers
would have had their hands yeah he was
abused he's big [ __ ]
he stood up and i was just like yeah
really yes
yeah some of those dudes it was just
funny when his wife was like
how did you get
i don't understand people and then
ladies i'm in 13c i'm like god damn it i
think sometimes i'm not flying southwest
some people you know what that's why you
flying southwest that but that the uh
those little uh flight attendant dude he
was not backing down the second one that
came through oh the ball yeah he was not
backing down you know what though he's
ready to get beat up people decide
they're going to they're it's worth all
the [ __ ] in that moment
a lot of men go you know this is worth
all the penalties and i think that's why
guys punch people in the face that's why
you see people get shot by the cops
there was a guy he was really sad man he
was just an older dude my age probably
big guy and the he was black and and he
was he had his wife there and this
little sort of white female cop was
mouthing she was saying stuff to him
like you know and he was like you guys
followed me here and i could tell he had
had enough
his you saw this in person no it was a
video okay his whole life had been
something and he had this this girl
isn't 23 telling this man is my age
who's probably going through a thousand
things his wife is trying to get him
back inside he's huge
and he's like okay no black guy he
starts clapping at the guy you knew the
guy he starts clapping at the thing he
watches his video on that okay he comes
down and he starts walking towards him
clapping and yelling at him clapping he
doesn't have a gun right now and they
shot him oh well that's not red it's
terrible but
he was moving towards them and then they
say you're coming towards me you're huge
you use a taser i agree with you but i'm
just saying there's sean
you could see he was done you could see
he was like
i just had it i'm not gonna do this
anymore and i'm gonna if i die [ __ ] it
some you can get in that position where
you're just like not in your right mind
that's a tough one i mean yeah how do
you think that's gonna end not well well
yeah i saw this thing on worldstar this
guy takes his uh lady hostage it's like
in a backyard like he was like beating
her took her hostage and the cops are
like
and they got you can tell the cops like
a bro he's like a young cop and they all
have their guns out because they have
the body cam on he's like dude i'm
telling you don't want to do this man
because it's not going to work out this
isn't going to work out for you i
promise you do not want to do this it's
not going to end well for you he's like
[ __ ] you and he does he has to let you
like this and his gun here and he just
kind of like literally just brings arm
like this then spoon yeah game sound
and then the rest of them
[ __ ] i mean they made sure that
[ __ ] was dead and people say
they why'd you already shoot so many
times a lot of guys will get shot five
times and return to grab the gun so they
want to go home so pop out there's a
white guy for the record white guy yeah
yeah yeah so he he just pulled his gun
up like he literally went through like
hey i'm in the boat
well you can't i saved the other lady i
used to watch he kept saying drop the
gun like that what you do in that
situation is you drop the guy he was
like a bro cop he's like i'm telling you
bro
bro he's like bro doesn't end well for
you bro yeah he said come on broski not
tonight broski and then they shot him
right in the heart
damn yeah why did they shoot the gun out
of that yeah there was a dude there was
a video of a guy and he had they tried
to rob a bank and then they caught him
and the guy they cornered him and the
guy's lying on a porch and he's got a
gun
he's holding the gun to his own chest
because he's going to kill himself right
and you just the cop just goes like this
cop says to his sergeant and he goes i
think i can shoot that gun
out of his hand oh my god because the
guy's an idiot he's lying there like
this and he's just got us he's it's kind
of in front of a bank and [ __ ] and he's
just holding the cops at bay
he's like i'm not i just can't go to
jail right i'd rather die so he's
sitting there
sir don't kill yourself drop the gun
it's going to be okay and the cop goes i
think i can shoot that gun right now
sergeant goes go ahead try it and he
just goes boom and shoots the gun and
the gun flies out of his hand and they
just cuffed oh damn he did wow
yeah
yeah yeah i figured i figured the guy
who was a star on the double shot
right so i was gonna say yeah
that's a dicey move man [ __ ] yeah man
yeah tough cops have a tough gig that's
a tough gig the toughest you're dealing
with sometimes with some crazy
[ __ ] who will kill you or shoot
your back
you know what do you got jen
all right start watching yellowstone oh
out of success new season november i
think well i'm only on first season oh
you got to catch up for the new season
it'll suck in it's great huh they suck
in
they're not
done
the duttons are not they're not angels
oh no no they're right so good they're
not angels
they're at the heavies chin how was your
showing uh
oh yeah
it was in austin yeah that's swandive
was it part of moon tower or no no but
the guys uh jeremiah watkins and stephen
they they stopped by for the show that's
cool unfortunately they couldn't do it
because they weren't on set the same
time we were on set at 11. um how's
awesome
i love it yeah yeah it's incredible the
shows went well it wasn't well well the
show went well i met a lot of people
left austin and now living in denver
makes sense
it does
did uh would you move to austin move
i mean i'd rather stay here yeah i like
visiting yeah yeah
nice view about you guys nice visit
i don't think you can do this i don't i
think awesome you could turn into a
small town right quick
that's not huge no
i like it but i think
there's a homeless population there too
though
it's pretty heavy
yeah pretty bad oh yeah it's also mini
la it's it's a blue basically yeah yeah
it's it's perfect
i thought they controlled their
or fixed that problem
oh no no no no on our way to the actual
venue there's a certain path we could
take to avoid it we're seeking
everywhere was the vinnie on 6th street
is that allie behind there it looks like
that one alley
from a [ __ ] horror movie yeah it
might be six years and
yeah we saw some like hot girl on a
scooter go down like oh my is she trying
to get raped like literally going
straight down this shady alley
really just it's just drugs like we saw
people doing like
needles in their arms and [ __ ] is that
right behind the vulcan it's the ghettos
[ __ ] yeah no no thanks i don't know
but i saw a bunch of homeless people oh
yeah yeah it's bad in austin yeah mm-hmm
oh they got a snooze out there we stand
where did we stay we stayed at the
hilton
nice hotel austin yeah
we stayed there when we went for uh you
and i together we a hot second ago for
yeah where did we stay it was a good
hotel i forget it's nice your that venue
wasn't off six reaching no not 6th
street
it was fun though it's a lot of fun a
lot of people come out a good amount of
people came out oh you know what's weird
the our biggest show was in ohio
and that's like such a rant i'm like a
portsmouth ohio it's not where he's from
there though he's from there too yeah
but still that was our biggest one yeah
that's where he's from the hometown yeah
what do you got this weekend where you
going denver remember oh that's right
i'm in chicago in chicago how many how
many um how many hours ahead of chicago
i think two hours yeah it's okay two
hours it's central time right
yeah i guess so 332 yep two hours
central city
be at the schomburg
chicago improv
they don't they call it schaumburg
i think yeah it's called schaumburg
i think we called chicago improv i think
i suppose that's the one we're doing in
december yeah no it's sh goddamn jen
okay there we go
i'm pretty sure it's called the
schomburg in the woodfield mall yeah
they don't call it the uh
improv comedy club in schaumburg yeah
yep all right improv comic club
schaumburg schaumburg so that's a
stretch from chicago i mean it'll be 40
minutes i usually stay in chicago but i
think i might stay i shouldn't right no
man that traffic chicago traffic is so
[ __ ] yeah i think i'll just
stay in schaumburg i've never done that
it's not too 56 minutes that's with
traffic too oh that's way too long
oh i remember you know last time i did
chicago one time i never tell you this
and i was on my way to the chamber
employment i was very late because well
there was a guy who was trying to jump
off
the bridge into traffic how to delay
things yep and and the you see the the
dude the firemen hanging off the [ __ ]
river talking yeah yeah yeah because he
can't have traffic so he's caught all
traffic and the guy's hair was like this
and he's shouting back at him like just
don't jump dude yeah remember last time
we played there we yeah we stayed like
downtown chicago and dude hour and a
half
two hours on friday
and even the schaumburg uh manager like
what are you doing there yeah i'm like
chicago man we don't be in the suburbs
right
it's tricky it's tricky tricky slope
tricky yeah all right what do you got
jim alrighty
first one
okay so this past saturday during a game
a ohio state linebacker quit uh during
the second quarter because he wasn't
substituted into the game after a heated
argument in the sidelines he was
escorted off the field he took off his
gloves threw it into the crowd and then
he went on a tweeting spree said from
the locker room yeah
yeah and put [ __ ] ohio stuff yeah he
said good luck to my teammates [ __ ] ohio
state he deleted him shortly after now
again that would be a guy who had a
moment he like your friend who is
sitting in the emergency room he's a
young guy i was like [ __ ] this and now
he's going to regret that for a very
long time he was a senior and throughout
his career at ohio state he was always a
backup i guess he was just frustrated
that he didn't get as much playing time
as he would have liked
season definitely ended early for him
so
that's not a guy who had any aspirations
to play in the end oh for sure yeah for
sure he did he did ohio state but even
if he's back up oh yeah even if you're
investigating i bet he was a five-star
recruit in high school oh [ __ ] superstar
wow yeah back up at ohio state how
[ __ ] good he is you got to be as good
as you're basically as good as a starter
yeah
wow
yeah you can't be on the team can't have
will he be asked back on if yeah
absolutely not they don't need them
there's another guy just as good waiting
behind
it doesn't cause all the distractions
well you can't say [ __ ] ohio state right
no tweak that a little aggressive
maybe maybe a little cte maybe you're
like oh god that's a cop out no he's
just dumbass yeah
okay so if you are staying in new york
city and you want an airbnb apparently
there are these glamping experiences
that you can do where you will basically
rent out a
van that's a home for the night and it
goes for about a hundred dollars every
night
and the city of new york is currently
going through the streets and repointing
a lot of these cars because they have
expired registrations they're really old
vans that a lot of customers say smell
and have a weird because you look too
poo in them yeah oh yeah well so mike i
was talking about how i had this fantasy
of living like out of a really cool van
so i could just drive everywhere i just
wanted i don't have and my girlfriend
stevie wanted to do that
like you do cool so
we get an airbnb i go down san diego
we're going to get an airbnb i'm way she
goes it's right here i go where
right here and for a hundred bucks she
had rented a [ __ ]
event
like uh but it was a one of those what
is it uh
yeah yeah yeah sure okay
sure great and she just sat there my
girl took her credit was like there you
go we're gonna stay there because i know
you have a fantasy of standards just
stay one night to see what it is
me the premium i look in there i go
that's the toilet and where's the shower
oh there's no shower oh you shout
outside on the uh um
like a gym or something yeah it's a van
dude yeah
and these vans in new york city are just
parked right up on a random street
corner is it these specific vans no no
usually they're older older versions of
this oh god they're not that so if you
don't have no showering if you're into
yeah no and you're lucky if there's a
restroom in it yeah [ __ ] that yeah i
mean and the restroom's weird-looking
it's also a vanity hard pass
yeah so imagine man's like that and
there are cars parallel parking
throughout the night right next to you
people walking by oh yeah talking on
their phones
no
100 bucks pretty cheap though true
there's a reason i know what you pay for
all righty
so
michael jordan's former security that
was on the last dance the guy with the j
crew i believe so he went and he is
currently selling so he passed away oh
he passed away okay well a security
guard that worked for michael jordan is
currently selling a bunch of his old
clothes that i guess he left behind
and it has dry cleaning tags on it and
his underwear actually sold recently for
almost three thousand dollars but
they're clean
uh they're clean but these pee pee
stains they
it was used not necessarily from peepee
stains or like streak marks but because
they're trying i don't want them dry
stains out the back the baby stains
for three grand though
no i'm not paying three grand for those
do you wear them do you frame them
probably why do you want them
you got skid marks you you frame them
you imagine watching somebody's house
like dude bought jordan's old underwear
bro check it out yeah like i'm i'm
leaving now yeah they tried to do it
beetles they would like cut out a piece
of like i know you can buy kirkland hair
you know yeah you can yeah yeah a girl
that cut his hair
uh kept
um kept some of it that's kind of which
is weird weird
[ __ ] right how weird is that
courtney love had his hair too tattoos
and they've it's all like i'll be like
it's like it's halloween inspired or
it's it's all pop music and you're like
oh
pop music tattoo would you be weirded
out uh one somebody who cut your hair
held on to it i'd sell it yeah i would
not never go back okay just want them to
yeah we're not making smart business
choices yeah it's not that end that'd be
[ __ ] weird yeah that's a creepy thing
to do too that girl made i think that
girl made like 20 grand off kirkland i'm
sure
she made a lot of money yeah
[ __ ] i think how long she's kept it for
yeah 94 is when he died i mean also
think of her motives
he leaves and she's like i'ma save this
yeah this is yeah royalty
well you could throw it in the trash or
make a hundred grand on it so
20 years ago you got options
alrighty
so squeeze girl up yeah this video so
there is a video going viral where jack
harlow is at a club appearance and a
girl tries to shoot her shot at him from
afar he's by the vip section she's in
the crowd so she starts typing on her
phone i have a fat ass so he will see it
and he responded back with i'm shy
and this video is going viral
i have a fat ass
he doesn't turn on that gun he put i'm
shy on his phone yeah
and they're just trying to get him to
party with uh the girls but he's not uh
jack harlow is a rabbit he's from your
hometown no he's from louisville yeah
and uh
but this is just what was he watching
the club but is that the girl right
there yeah that's the girl oh no i'm
saying is that her profile below that
no oh she's a baddie she is looked into
it damn kyle
let me bring it i wanted to see if she
really did she's a baddie oh yeah yeah
yeah what is it i see the profile um
what is it this is her name's like
maddie day this is my script they're at
a club and those kids are just staring
at jack carlo while he like drinks and
[ __ ]
looks like it it's [ __ ] awkward yeah
a lot of those uh celebrity guest
appearances are though you just kind of
go
straight to jack harlow for a bit yeah
she's doing all right in the uh the dump
truck area you you found her better be
if she's gonna say i have a fat ass yeah
she shouldn't [ __ ] i have a fat ass
i can't see
christian is liking all of her photos as
we speak i don't think she's just just
just show chin yeah well i i i'm setting
up so i can shoot my shot later
your shot yeah
short key yeah all right why not roll it
in there she shot her shot everybody's
shooting shots tell her you got a fat
you know oops got a fat ass too though
so i might have to compete with her on
that i don't know if she wants that's
followed by christian
see paulo
that's from the left right that's around
the left yes she's 17. yeah what is 17
no i think she's in college uh to be in
the clubs yesterday at least 21. yeah
but
i'm about to unfollow keep scrolling
down
i don't i'm not seeing any ass there it
is
okay
i don't know if that's jack harlow
material yeah probably not
all right kyle
all right cal i didn't i didn't find
indoor dm but i didn't she's very cute
she's cute
you're back on the you're back on the
day now what you're back on dating apps
yeah back on the day we didn't work out
with old girl from arizona you know it
just it's got to be 50 50. the distance
yeah i just i can't travel there every
weekend and uh she didn't want to come
to travel everywhere she didn't want to
come to l.a so i was like well it's not
going to work
yep on to the next
that sucks
well maddie uh
[Music]
kyle here
there you go
yes there you go buddy well
oh that's
was that the the first one was her it's
hilarious i got a fat ass
that's so hard
very cute good for her
yeah she's shot she looks 14. she looks
so young
you couldn't get any creepier in there
she's drinking that she's 21.
yeah um or acting 21. so this just
happened right now
kelly is strong
also like wow for racketeering too or
something like that
yeah what is racketeering trafficking
right uh look right now
trafficking
sex trafficking those are major oh dear
[ __ ] all counts in federal sex crime wow
verdict on nine federal accounts clean
racketeering sex crimes human
trafficking obstruction of just
kidnapping he's [ __ ] yeah yeah uh
clown for more witness defense kelly's
team one called five witnesses all right
keep going kelly never took the stand
that's usually never good
my name is very kim just were tears
kelly was in chicago mary this all start
from that documentary remember that yeah
all this started from that documentary
so this and the jinx keeps going down
apparently uh he didn't discriminate
guys and gals
to hook up with what yeah one of the
guys who went on the stand was saying
how r kelly was like how about you want
to be in music and then i was like damn
here's my
rb singing dick is that right
wait i thought the story was r kelly
gave him head
either way gay cat you know yeah fair
yeah i like that you're detailed but
yeah
be gay it's fair
it's say uh decades in prison wow oh
[ __ ] i like people like he's innocent
there's like a fight for it fans but i
remember a long time ago when there was
a video of him peeing on a 14 year old
and i was like
and i just went away i was like what
they're like in a steamer yeah how the
[ __ ] did that go that just went away
and then he got in that thing uh
aaliyah's parents were pissed because
they were she was 15 he got her pregnant
she had an abortion they said
15 dude and he was 27 at the time
well that's we secretly got married
crazy right but the parent what's
interesting about that wait i heard they
signed off on it yeah the parents saying
take some responsibility do they face
their paperwork oh they signed off
that's what they're saying yeah oh yeah
the parents were like you know all about
it i guess oh either way he's going away
for a hot second hostage trafficking
yeah [ __ ]
no more tunes from him he'll sing in
jail
all right here's a couple of fights from
fans at sporting events
we saw the browns one last week did we
hear yep yeah yeah
okay
yep
my brain's not working this one kansas
city chiefs no no all right here we go
[Applause]
the primacy the team's not doing very
well
just a sea of red
[Applause]
[Applause]
opposing teams oh no no i just hit that
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
wow that guy just snuck the other
oh [ __ ]
god where's security oh
oh oh that's an old man
that's not good i guess you want to see
that stuff
[Laughter]
that was aggressive
so now
[Music]
who got the best of them here it looks
like the other team
oh gosh
do you think this happens they're all
chief fans yeah i've seen it happen so
you think it's just been a very few
football games i've seen it happen
plenty of times there's just a footage
just showing up more but it happens all
day there's a lot of fights in football
stance seems like it's happening more
yeah it does oh
all right so i saw this
i don't know how he stole this but
someone stole an ipad
for disney world and if they use it to
like you know have people come to the
front of the line or whatever the
official ipad yeah disneyland yeah and
he was he was actually actually having
tours with with some of the people there
too
and getting skipping lines and all that
stuff the lines are long as [ __ ] these
days yeah
did he get busted you got busted and
what happens to him i think he's just
he's not allowed there ever again oh wow
yeah damn for life
i can't go to disneyland for the rest of
your life
he's like why world or is he banned from
i know that's a good question it's all
of them yeah walt disney don't [ __ ]
around
yeah so they were they investigated they
found out what he was trying to get to
another line with and they cancelled it
and he they found coming up or something
like that
i get the hustle man those lines are
insane so you have kids yeah he's
probably by himself though so that makes
it weird
all right um
a couple of things were tagged in this
one i don't know why oh is this what
oh that sounds oh
oh wow look at that big horse dick
that's a really bad situation god get
out from underneath him dumbass gotta
get out from here he got out and he
slaps him he's all slapped
he's a jockey yeah he's a jockey he's a
little that looks like a huge like a
clydesdale though right yeah
he slaps him right there awesome he
slapped the horse
and uh this one they say looks like
brian this is a real boxer
i know
wow
for almost 2 000 rounds yeah they always
and those [ __ ] gloves
i've seen video on that guy
that's old-timey boxing wilderness
look at their kicks
yeah
his gloves are i mean it's just leather
straight up like mitts
so yeah the greatest defensive
boxer
that could be you be i know
that's how i fight and i saw this as
well and it made me cry hopefully
you guys don't cry as well but check it
out wait what i'll show you real quick
here it is with that
so it says have you some friends like he
does is a wedding
i don't like the grammar but
but check it out so obviously he's in a
wheelchair
and there is no audio to this oh that's
cool all right oh so now these guys are
taking their legs to his oh that's
[ __ ] cool that's cool
oh that's total
wow it's a great idea oh man what the
hell happened
let me refresh this again
we gotta wait
oh there's more to it yeah there's more
to it there's more to it i probably
would have cried for that grandpa have
you get some friends that can do this
have you surprised that he does
all right
so the audio people
there's two people beside him on the
left and the right the guy can't walk so
it looks like the best man in the father
yeah the father sits down next to him
and they're tying their legs together
mm-hmm oh i know
he's gonna put his arms around they're
gonna also yeah that's [ __ ] your
mom's running
hopefully that's really cool what the
hell this sucks okay anyways but they he
they do a dance they the one the wife
comes in and they just dance together oh
that's awesome
dance i wish we could get a song i know
this sucks oh [ __ ] i wish i had that
video which video the one the big the
big dude running the relay that they
were tagging saying it was me so fast
wait that gorilla's jealous you can go
down
what is this
all
right i hope this is good
okay well no anyways what else you got
jen that was it man
okay all right well well listen i think
we covered a lot of ground
you're trying to do with those fights
oh um
so i did a little research on
i did a little research on um kayla
plant a little more
and uh i'm still i'm still
he gets hit he's a great boxer yeah he's
undefeated he's a great boxer knox feels
fine he's not afraid
nobody is not that long highly skilled
yep and uh give me my [ __ ] money oh
no no he's going the distance
and winning
that's very very tall order for canelo
but if there's anybody that's going to
beat canelo it's caleb plant love it
okay well yes you got a grand on it
daddy yeah i got a ground on it
can you fast forward it chen i wish i
could i wish i could i'm just praying
that this one will work this time it's a
different browser have you some friends
like he do
all right
have you seen all right
have you some friends like he does
yeah i mean it's people say that all the
time
you could worry a little bit come on
let's work this is gonna work please
this is it right here
this is the one i'm gonna cry this time
there we go here we go it's working
working keep watching
tall guy i wonder why he's in a
wheelchair probably i know i don't know
the story behind it
but then they're dancing here oh that's
really cool
watch your hands papa
that's pretty cool yeah that's pretty
cool that is cool that's a tough one
awesome we made it look at her we got
the video there we go all right here we
go
that's good
all right
well i'm i have i have some friends
are you
i'm not after watching that you said bro
i maybe i first it took us seven years
we didn't have a good build up to it
i have some friends and we're gonna be
in denver colorado this thursday friday
saturday two shows friday two shows
saturday one show thursdays david poston
chappelle lacy myself at the comedy
works downtown denver mama got your
tickets cody donovan i got your tickets
please start bowling get your tickets uh
las vegas nevada next week wise guys
october 7th through october 9th brea
california october 15th through october
17th and then the big boy special night
dallas texas november 11th through the
13th off more info as we get closer
thank you to fatkz.com
sorry it's all good bring me up
chicago
improv i'm here
uh yeah refresh
30th
october 1 october 2. we've got to change
that columbus ohio
funny bone october 8th and 9th and then
in timonium maryland magooby's joke
house owned by the people that own lol
in san antonio
daddy's doing a lot of flying
columbus
big stretches
yeah
there's going to be some miles
i'm doing some flying too october 7th
through the 9th tampa florida side
splitters and then octo i know and then
october yeah i'm flying again october
28th through the 30th washington dc the
dc comedy loft boom love it go get em
kids denver see this weekend love you
guys we're out bam